the Loch Ness monster is one of our most
enduring men people have sought its
secrets for over 1500 years but only one
man has devoted his entire life to
learning the truth alone in a dam by the
law
and no he's not a wacko
it's just his thing my name's Dee Felton
and for the last 25 years I've been a
full-time hunter of the Loch Ness
monster I first came to like this when I
was a seven-year-old boy and found this
set of caravans with this gang of grown
men hunting for monsters in Loch Ness
and I thought that's amazing that would
be the life for me I'd love to do that
and so he did
25 years ago he quit his job sold his
house bought his van and pursued his
passion he now holds the Guinness record
for the longest continuous search at
Loch Ness in all my time here I've only
seen one possible sighting of something
all you saw was a spray of water off of
the back of something off like a torpedo
going shooting through to this day that
remains the mystery to me as to what
that was that was in the first year of
being here and I thought right this job
should be really easy
that's one sighting 25 years later I'm
still sat here waiting for that second
sighting some people think it's giant
eels some people think there's a ripping
time others believe as a spaceship on
the bottom of the law
more likely to turn out to be big
catfish than a spaceship on the bottom
of the law the reason I sit here and I
try and solve this mystery is because
that's what makes my heart sing
people say is it lifestyle or is it the
mystery it's both my life contains
freedom adventure unpredictability and
the chance of one of the world's
greatest discovery should I ever happen
to find nothing it's a dream come true
that little seven-year-old boy could see
what became of him even believe is luck
[Music]